now I want to come back to the topic of
natural user interfaces one of the most
natural interfaces for people is human
speech and for the last 60 years
computer scientists have been trying to
find ways to understand and recognize
human speech now in the beginning when
people first started tackling this
problem they looked at it largely as a
pattern matching problem and the
earliest systems attempted to take the
waveforms that came out of a speaker's
speaker's voice and match them up to
waveforms that they knew represented
certain words
unfortunately that approach is extremely
fragile
partly because everyone speaks
differently but also even a single
speaker will often say the same thing
differently depending on the other words
or the context in which they're speaking
you've probably already noticed me doing
that now in the late 1970s there was a
major change in the way people decided
to do speech recognition this was work
being done at Carnegie Mellon University
and the idea was to use a statistical
modeling technique in this case hidden
Markov model to make the transitive to
really be able to take a lot of data
from many speakers and produce more
robust statistical models of speech now
that was a huge improvement and over the
last 30 years speech recognition systems
have become dramatically better than
they used to be they still make a lot of
mistakes but in in limited domains
it's possible to do very successful
speech interfaces so for example in the
United States when I call my bank I'm
talking to a computer I'm not talking to
a person the computer can answer simple
questions about my bank account or if
necessary it can connect me to a real
person if I have a significant issue
that I want to discuss I'm sure you've
heard of Apple Siri products which
answers simple questions Microsoft
Connect has a robust speech interface
that allows you to control the interface
and even allows you to issue commands in
the middle of games still these systems
have a lot of errors and the error rates
for arbitrary speech have been in the 20
to 25 percent rank well a few years ago
researchers at Microsoft Research at the
University of Toronto came together to
develop with another breakthrough in the
field of speech recognition research the
idea that they have was to use a
technology in a way patterned after the
way the human brain works it's called
deep neural networks and to use that to
take it much more data than had
previously been able to be used with the
hidden Markov models and use that to
significantly improve recognition rates
so that one changed that particular
breakthrough increased recognition rates
by approximately 30 percent that's a big
deal that's the difference between going
from 20 to 25% errors or about one error
out of every four or five words to
roughly 15% or slightly less errors
roughly one out of every seven words
perhaps even one out of every aide so
it's still not perfect there's still a
long way to go but I think you can see
that we have already made a significant
amount of additional progress in the
recognition of speech now one of the
problems that we've also been trying to
solve for 60 years is machine
translation and again in just the last
few years the combination of statistical
techniques and big data have allowed us
to do a much better job than we
previously were able to do in being able
to translate webpages or other kinds of
information into other languages for
example today they translate which is
Microsoft translation system that comes
out of Microsoft Research big translate
translates millions of pages a day for
users into their native language it's
extremely heavily used service now if I
want to have what I'm saying be
translated into Chinese we can take the
text that comes from my voice and put
that through a translation system it
really happens in two steps in the first
instance we take the English and we
convert it more or less word by word
into into Chinese text and I think
pretty soon we may see that up on the
screen so what happens is we're
basically taking the English text and
pushing it through the translation
system we then have to reorder that text
in Chinese because the word order in
Chinese is not the same as the word or a
rating would to produce something that
begins to resemble something that a
Chinese
mindset so now we're taking the things
that I'm saying
and we're converting them into Chinese
text now the last step that I want to be
able to take in this process is to
actually speak to you in Chinese now the
key thing there is we've been able to
take a large amount of information from
many Chinese speakers and produce a
text-to-speech system that takes Chinese
text and converts it into Chinese
language and then we've taken an hour or
so of my own voice and we've used that
to modulate the standard text-to-speech
system so that it would sound like me so
what you see now is the result of that
change I'm speaking in English and
hopefully you'll hear me speak in
Chinese in my own voice
again the results are not perfect there
are in fact quite a bit errors Jude
walking pool unmade there's much work to
be done in this area
time to communion tofu so it goes well
with this technology is very promising
human to the T short videos you love
then we hope in a few years that we'll
be able to break down the language
barriers between people
soon info woman she loved them both how
cool didn't you didn't
personally I believe this is going to
lead to a better world - or the age of
jell-o Jason thought there should you I
hope you enjoy the rest of the
presentations today chimo continue to
punch you have a chance
thank you
see ya